so we now focus on the Iranian past
problem and try to learn more about de
Bruin graphs so we saw that to
reconstruct the genome we need to find
an algorithm pass in this graph but some
of you noticed that I cheated I
constructed the d-brane graph from
genome but in real life genome is
unknown the only thing that is known is
reads or Kaymer's can be reconstruct the
d-brane graph from genome composition
rather than from genome well let's try
to do this but let's first review what
we have done what we have shown is that
given a genome we can construct the
bhangra what we want to do is given
genome composition or k-mer composition
of the genome we want to construct the
gene what we will show now is that given
k-mer composition we can construct the
brain graph and then using Euler's
inside construct all variant passes in
this graph let's start so in the past we
construct we started from a path
representing the genome but now genome
is unknown what is known is only
composition of the genome and we will
represent this composition every element
every stream are in composition by an
edge we will now construct also nodes of
this graph by representing them as
tumors as we did before now to construct
the brain graph from k-mer composition
let's do exactly the same we did before
let's just glue identically labelled
nodes for example a a an a a identically
labeled let's glue them together bring
them a little bit closer and finally
glue let's continue this 80 the same
thing GC continue continue continue
continue continue continue continue
continue again more more and fine
we are getting the same path that we
were getting Esav genome would be known
but we haven't done yet this gluon
because there are of course are the
vertices to glue and we press it exactly
the same way as we were proceeding in
the case when genome was known and
finally construct the d-brane graph so
what we have just shown that even in the
case genome is unknown we can construct
the same deep brain graph as in the case
the genome is known and this is great
which means that the next step we need
to address is how to find all variant
passes in Zildjian so for construction
of the brain graves algorithm 'pl we
simply need to represent every Kaymer
as an edge between its prefix and its
suffix and afterward glue all nodes of
these identical labels it is it to line
algorithm if you implemented that you
have already figure out that there is a
different way to look at de bruin graph
if they are given a collection of caner
we can form nodes of the graph of all k
minus 1 mayors from this collection and
for each Kaymer from the composition
they can connect it's perfect note
movies its suffix node by an edge these
are two equivalent definition of the
d-brane graph and now let me explain
what was de bruin contribution to this
area and why these graphs are called de
bruin graphs the brain graphs have great
applications of biology in biology but
de Bruin of course did not know this
because he was interested in purely
mathematical abstract problem he tried
to solve so-called Universal stream
problem which is finding a circle string
containing each binary Kaymer exactly
once here all a binary k-mers can we
find a stream that contains each of them
exactly once we can this is a string and
if you check for each binary swimmers
you will find it
Piron Kansas train can learn the circle
if you travel along the circle clockwise
for example for this streamer it appears
along the circle but how can we
construct the string is it even possible
for all possible values of K well the
only simply need to do we need to
represent each of this binary camera as
an edge right because it should be a
k-mer composition of the strength we are
trying to find afterwards we need to
construct the brain graph from these
isolated edges and the d-brane graph
will look like this and afterwards
simply look for all variant cycles in
these graph cycles rather than passes
because the brain was interested in
finding circle string can you find an
ovarian cycle in this graph and how can
it help us to find a universal string
let's say let's start working here and
the immediately can get insight into the
first three elements of the string let's
continue this way and when we travel
through the graph the string is
enlarging and enlarging and in lunging
and finally be constructed to Universal
strings the fact that the graph is
already implies that every Kaymer
appears exactly once in this circular
string but what about this for universal
string constructed from all formers what
about ten all ten mares in this case the
graph will consist of thousands note
does it have an ovarian cycle if yes how
can we find it will answer this question
in the next segment